J'ai envie de vous parler d'un conflit oublié.
Un conflit qui fait rarement la une des journaux.
Ça se passe ici-même, en République Démocratique du Congo.
Mais peu de personnes hors de l'Afrique connaissent la guerre au Congo,
alors laissez-moi vous donner quelques éléments-clefs.
Le conflit congolais est le plus mortel depuis la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
Il est à l'origine de presque 4 millions de morts.
Il déstabilise la majeure partie d'Afrique Centrale depuis 18 ans.
C'est la plus importante crise humanitaire dans le monde.
C'est pour cela que je suis allée au Congo en 2001.
J'étais une jeune envoyée humanitaire, et j'ai rencontré cette femme de mon âge.
Elle s'appelait Isabelle.
Des milices locales ont attaqué le village d'Isabelle.
Ils ont tué beaucoup d'hommes, violé beaucoup de femmes.
Ils ont tout pris.
Puis ils ont voulu prendre Isabelle,
Son mari s'est interposé,
disant : « Non, s'il vous plaît, ne prenez pas Isabelle.
Prenez-moi à sa place. »
Il est donc parti dans la forêt avec les miliciens,
et Isabelle ne l'a jamais revu.
Eh bien, c'est pour des gens comme Isabelle et son mari
que j'ai voué ma carrière à étudier ce conflit
dont nous savons si peu.
Il y a cependant une histoire que vous avez dû entendre sur le Congo.
Sur la terre et le viol.
Les rapports de police et les media
se concentrent généralement sur la première cause de violence au Congo :
l'exploitation illégale et le trafic des ressources naturelles,
et sur la principale conséquence :
le viol des femmes et fillettes comme arme de guerre.
Bien que ces problèmes soient très graves,
je veux vous raconter une autre histoire aujourd'hui.
Je veux vous parler d'une histoire pointant un problème au cœur
du conflit actuel.
La violence au Congo est largement due à des conflits d'intérêt locaux
que les forces de paix internationales n'ont pu résoudre.
L'histoire commence avec le fait que le Congo est connu non seulement
pour être le théâtre de la pire catastrophe humanitaire en cours,
mais aussi pour être le sujet de certains
des plus importants efforts de paix au niveau mondial.
La plus importante et la plus coûteuse des missions
de paix des Nations Unies est au Congo.
C'était aussi le théâtre de la première mission européenne de paix
et pour ses premiers procès, la Cour Pénale Internationale
a choisi de poursuivre des seigneurs de guerre congolais.
En 2006, lorsque le Congo organisait ses premières élections nationales libres,
de nombreux observateurs crurent que cela mettrait fin à la violence dans la région.
La communauté internationale loua le succès de l'organisation des élections
comme un exemple de la réussite de l'intervention internationale
dans un état à feu et à sang.
Mais les provinces de l'Est
ont continué à vivre d'importants déplacements de population
et d'horribles violations des Droits de l'Homme.
Peu avant mon séjour là-bas l'été dernier,
il a eu un terrible massacre dans la province du Sud-Kivu.
Trente-trois personnes furent tuées.
En majorité des femmes et des enfants,
et nombreux furent battus à mort.
Durant les huit dernières années,
les combats dans les provinces de l'Est ont souvent redéclenché
des guerres civiles et internationales de grande ampleur.
Pour faire simple, dès que nous pensons arriver à une situation de paix,
le conflit s'embrase.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi l'énorme effort international
n'a-t-il pas réussi à établir au Congo une paix et une sécurité durables ?
Eh bien, ma réponse tourne autour de deux constats.
Premièrement, l'une des causes principales de la perpétuelle violence au Congo
est principalement locale.
Et lorsque je dis local,
je parle vraiment au niveau de l'individu, de la famille,
le clan, la municipalité, la communauté, le district,
et parfois le groupe ethnique.
Par exemple, vous vous souvenez de l'histoire d'Isabelle.
La raison pour laquelle les milices ont attaqué le village d'Isabelle
est qu'ils voulaient s'emparer de la terre
dont les villageois avaient besoin pour leurs cultures et leur survie.
Le second constat est que les efforts de paix internationaux
n'ont pas réussi à régler les problèmes locaux
à cause de la présence d'une culture dominante de la paix.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que
les diplomates occidentaux et africains,
les forces des Nations Unies, les donateurs,
le personnel de la plupart des ONG
qui œuvrent à la résolution du conflit,
partagent tous une même vision du monde.
Et j'étais une de ces personnes, je partageais cette vision,
alors je connais bien son influence.
À travers le monde, à travers les zones de conflits,
cette même vision incite les acteurs pour la paix
à interpréter les causes des conflits
plutôt aux niveaux nationaux et internationaux.
Elle façonne notre vision du chemin vers la paix
comme nécessitant une intervention à haut niveau
pour régler les tensions nationales et internationales.
Et elle façonne notre opinion sur le rôle des acteurs étrangers
sur les processus de paix nationaux et internationaux.
Et plus important encore, le partage de cette vision
incite les acteurs de paix internationaux à ignorer les tensions au niveau local
qui souvent déstabilisent les institutions de plus grande taille.
Ainsi, au Congo,
de par leur culture et leur formation,
les officiels onusiens, donateurs, diplomates,
le personnel de la plupart des ONG
voient les constants conflits et massacres comme un problème structurel.
Pour eux, la violence à laquelle ils assistent
découle de tensions entre le président Kabila
et plusieurs opposants nationaux,
et des tensions entre le Congo, le Rwanda et l'Ouganda.
De plus, les acteurs internationaux pour la paix voient les conflits locaux
comme le simple résultat de tensions nationales et internationales,
d'un manque d'autorité du gouvernement,
et de ce qu'ils appellent l'attirance congolaise naturelle pour la violence.
Cette vision générale fait voir l'intervention
aux niveaux national et international
comme la seule logique et légitime mission
des envoyés des Nations Unies et des diplomates.
Et elle place la tenue d'élections nationales,
qui aujourd'hui jouent le rôle de remède miracle,
au centre du procédé de reconstruction,
au lieu d'approches de construction étatique plus efficaces.
Et ceci n'arrive pas qu'au Congo,
mais dans beaucoup d'autres zones de conflit.
Mais approfondissons
les autres causes de violence.
Au Congo, la perpétuelle violence est alimentée non seulement
par des considérations nationales et internationales,
mais aussi par de vieilles intrigues issues de la base de la société
dont les instigateurs sont des villageois, des chefs spirituels,
des chefs de tribus ou d'ethnies.
Beaucoup de conflits tournent autour
d'enjeux politiques, sociaux et économiques de dimension purement locale.
Par exemple, il y a beaucoup de concurrence
dans les villages ou districts
pour l'élection du chef du village ou chef du territoire
selon les traditions,
et qui gère la distribution des terres
et l'exploitation des sites miniers locaux.
Cette compétition entraîne souvent des conflits localisés,
par exemple dans un village ou un territoire,
qui bien souvent se transforment en conflits généralisés,
touchant toute une province,
et parfois même contaminant les pays voisins.
Prenons le conflit entre les Congolais d'origine rwandaise
et les communautés dites autochtones du Kivu.
Le conflit commença dans les années 30, pendant l'ère coloniale belge,
lorsque ces deux communautés
se disputaient l'accès et le contrôle du territoire et du pouvoir local.
L'indépendance du Congo déclarée, en 1960,
le conflit dégénéra, car chaque parti voulaient des représentants nationaux,
dans le but d'atteindre leurs objectifs personnels.
Ainsi, lors du génocide de 1994 au Rwanda,
ils se sont alliés aux groupes armés congolais et rwandais,
toujours pour obtenir ce qu'ils voulaient pour les provinces du Kivu.
Depuis lors, ces désaccords locaux sur la terre et le pouvoir
ont nourri le besoin de violence,
mettant régulièrement en péril
les accords nationaux et internationaux.
Nous pouvons donc nous interroger comment, dans ces circonstances,
les acteurs de paix internationaux n'ont pas réalisé le besoin
d'inciter à mettre en place des programmes de paix au niveau local.
Et la réponse est que les émissaires internationaux
ont jugé la tâche de résoudre des conflits à un niveau local
comme inutile, illogique et ne relevant pas de leur responsabilité.
La simple idée de se mêler de problèmes locaux
s'oppose totalement avec les principes de cette vision,
et elle va à l'encontre des intérêts des institutions majeures.
Par exemple, l'identité même des Nations Unies
comme organisation à dimension internationale
serait remise en cause si elle venait à se concentrer sur des conflits locaux.
Et le fait est que ni l'opposition interne
à la manière traditionnelle de travailler,
ni les électrochocs externes
n'ont réussi à convaincre les acteurs internationaux de revoir
leur vision de la violence et de la manière d'intervenir.
Jusque là, il y a eu très peu d'exceptions.
Il y en a eu, mais très peu,
à cette méthode générale.
Donc pour résumer, l'histoire que je viens de vous raconter
porte sur la manière dont une vision communément partagée du processus de paix
modèle la compréhension qu'ont les acteurs des origines de la violence,
de comment la paix est obtenue,
et que seront les objectifs d'une intervention.
Ces préjugés permettent aux acteurs de paix internationaux
d'ignorer les constituants de la base
qui sont si nécessaires au maintien de la paix.
L'insouciance face aux conflits localisés entraîne la mise en place
d'un processus de paix inadapté sur le court terme
et d'importantes chances de reprise des conflits sur le long terme.
Et le fascinant ici est que cette analyse
nous aide à mieux comprendre pourquoi certains conflits s'éternisent et
l'échec de l'intervention internationale, en Afrique et ailleurs.
Les conflits locaux alimentent la violence
dans la plupart des guerres et après-guerres,
de l'Afghanistan au Soudan, en passant par le Timor Oriental,
et dans de rares cas, il y a eu mise en place d'un processus de paix
soucieux des problèmes locaux,
permettant l'installation avec succès d'une paix durable.
L'un des meilleurs exemples est le contraste
entre la relative paix au Somaliland,
qui a profité d'importantes initiatives d'instauration de paix au niveau local,
et l'omniprésente violence dans le reste de la Somalie,
où les efforts de paix se concentraient surtout sur les institutions étatiques.
Et il y a plusieurs autres cas
où la résolution de conflits locaux
a eu un impact décisif.
Donc si nous voulons que les efforts de paix internationaux soient effectifs,
en parallèle à n'importe quelle intervention au niveau étatique,
les conflits doivent être réglés depuis la base de la structure du pays.
De nouveau, ce n'est pas dire que les tensions internationales et nationales
ne sont pas importantes. Elles le sont.
Et il ne s'agit pas de dire que
les efforts de paix nationaux et internationaux sont inutiles.
Ils sont utiles.
Mais il s'agit de dire que
les processus de paix ont besoin d'actions au niveau du pays et au niveau local
pour faire perdurer la paix,
et que les ONG locales,
les autorités locales et les représentants de la société civile
doivent être les principaux acteurs de ces actions à la base.
Bien sûr, il y a des obstacles.
Les acteurs locaux manquent souvent de fonds et parfois des moyens techniques
pour mener localement des programmes de paix efficaces.
Ainsi les acteurs internationaux devraient augmenter leur investissement et soutien
à la résolution des conflits locaux.
Et pour le Congo, que pouvons-nous faire ?
Après deux décennies de tensions et des millions de morts,
il est évident que nous avons besoin de changer notre approche.
En me basant sur les recherches dans mon domaine,
je pense que les acteurs internationaux et congolais
devraient se concentrer plus sur la résolution des conflits locaux
et sur la promotion de la réconciliation entre communautés.
Par exemple, dans la province du Kivu,
le Life and Peace Institute et ses partenaires congolais
ont mis en place des forums inter-communautaires
pour discuter de chaque désaccord sur la terre,
et ces forums ont trouvé des solutions pour réduire les effusions de sang.
C'est ce type de programme dont on a si désespérément besoin
dans tout l'Est du Congo.
C'est avec de tels programmes
que nous pourrons aider des personnes comme Isabelle et son mari.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un coup de baguette magique,
mais parce qu'ils prennent en compte les origines profondes de la violence,
ils pourraient vraiment inverser la tendance.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)